got a question for you though you came
up as a second baseman and then you're
gonna just move to the Outfield and win
every gold glove you need a shortstop
I'll move the short real quick we turn
double plays like it ain't nothing when
I just moved to center field or move to
left like that's an outfield position
but that's still a tough adjustment but
to go from The Outfield to the infield
the next day you're playing right when I
was playing Summer Ball coming up I
didn't have one team I played on I had
like four teams I played on the reason
why is because I split a lot of my time
playing basketball I would go to like
two basketball tournaments to one
baseball tournament so they would call
me like hey we need a third baseman this
week we need to come play short this
week we need to come play second this
week we need you to come play center
this week and so I grew up doing it and
then I got drafted as a shortstop and
enfield's my life bro it's my life it's
the most fun I have planned